[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle saison d'europe et
de nous démarrons par une journée
spéciale dont quatre à ce bourg et comme
chaque semaine nous aurons le plaisir
donc de décrypter ce qui fait
l'actualité européenne avec mes invités
donc au menu de cette émission spéciale
près de la cathédrale de strasbourg
l'éternelle bataille du siège dans les
traités donc le parlement européen est
situé à strasbourg mais depuis des
années une frange de parlementaires
souhaitent arrêter ces polluantes et
coûteuses transhumance mensuelle de
bruxelles à strasbourg
ce qui fait bien entendu bondir la
france on en débat dans quelques minutes
mais d'abord l'actualité les images ont
profondément choqué l'europe et ce
dimanche 1er octobre jour de référendum
sur l'indépendance de la catalogne
restera dans les mémoires comme le jour
où mariano la fin du premier ministre
espagnol a fait un usage disproportionné
de la force certes la consultation est
il légal
mais les dizaines de blessés et la grève
générale de ce mardi risque bien de
radicaliser encore les positions pendant
ce temps l'union européenne et les
voisins de madrid observe un silence
embarrassé pour en débattre mais invités
florent marcellesi bonjour 1 vous êtes
député vert et espagnol vous êtes du
pays basque c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
bon bienvenue à vous en face de vous
edouard martin bonjour vous êtes député
français et vous êtes on nous sommes ici
sur vos terres vous êtes député
socialiste bienvenue à vous enfin gérard
deprez vous êtes belge et vous êtes
membre du groupe libéral démocrate
bienvenue avant de débattre de la
catalogne on écoute bien entendu le
président de la région carlès pour pau
pouces damon pardon et mariano rajoy
en ce jour d'espoir et de souffrance les
citoyens de la catalogne ont gagné le
droit d'avoir un état indépendant qui
prennent la forme d'une république forme
vers la pauvre les cas on compte chaque
once chien par conséquent le
gouvernement que je préside annoncera au
parlement siège et expression de la
souveraineté de notre peuple
les résultats de la journée pour agir en
accord avec ce qui est prévu dans la loi
du référendum
un voyage dans la falaise et moi je
comble et donc
comme nostra obligations nous avons
rempli nos obligations nous avons agi
comme nous le disons depuis le début
selon la loi et uniquement selon la loi
il a été montré que notre état
démocratique a les moyens pour se
défendre contre une attaque aussi
sérieuse que celle qui a été tenté
avec ce référendum illégal quand les
stars fall and où il a garé faire un ami
légale mais qui a jeté sept cent mille
personnes dans la rue ce mardi florent
marcellesi qu'avez vous à dire de la
réaction de madrid sur ce dossier est ce
que vous estimez comme beaucoup en
catalogne que mahler dollars foyer et
délégitimé sur ce dossier ba est
clairement ce qui s'est passé dimanche
et c'est une honte pour beaucoup d'entre
nous on ne peut pas régler un problème
politique juste à coups de police et à
coups de justice malheureusement a été
totalement insensible à la cause fait
plusieurs années déjà qu'on a ce
problème ils ignorent totalement ce qui
est train de se passer en catalogne et
ils envoient la police régler un
problème politique on a besoin de
dialogue maintenant et en même temps on
à l'autre côté on a plus de monde
effectivement qui continue sa fuite en
avant sur l'égalité donc on a vraiment
actuellement un double problème c'est
l'incompétence de la rouille une plus
une incompétence une incapacité capacité
de comprendre ce qui se passe en
catalogne et en même temps une fuite en
avant du land en catalan dont on a
vraiment besoin l'union européenne
arrivent et disent voilà on va vous
mettre autour d'une table
il faut dialoguer parce que la seule
solution la politique c'est la médiation
européenne parce que là vraiment ça peut
être très très très mal finir qu'est ce
que vous avez en dire et douars martin
daniel cohn bendit disait la semaine
dernière que entre push des mandalas
royaume avait affaire à deux fous et
qu'effectivement il fallait une
médiation européenne ce que pour
l'instant refuse la commission je me
garderai bien de donner des leçons à qui
que ce soit c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible
il faut qu'on fasse très attention parce
que beaucoup de pays européens ne sont
pas l'abri d'avoir la même situation que
celle que nous vivons actuellement en
pologne
je pense notamment à notre pays la corse
1 entre autres mais ce que je partage
l'avis de florence c'est à dire que nous
avons quelqu'un d'à côté d'incompétents
et d'un autre côté un obstiné et
effectivement il ya peu de place pour le
dialogue et il faut que la solution soit
une solution politique
de là à dire que l'europe doit jouer le
médiateur moi je me garderai bien de
tout ça je pense que la démocratie
espagnole démocratie catalanes sont
assez mûrs pour pouvoir trouver le
contexte dans lequel on puisse
effectivement avoir un débat apaisé et
trouver une solution qui convienne aux
deux parties qui pour cette médiation
sachant que même le roi felipe dans une
adresse à la nation mardi soir à 21h a
été extrêmement aussi du rhin vis-à-vis
du camp catalan je pense que des deux
côtés vous savez en dehors de rares oeil
plus de monde il ya quand même et des
catalans et aider des espagnols parce
que le 14 comme des espagnols as et
sensée et qui veulent effectivement
trouvé un espace apaisé pour débattre et
c'est trouver des solutions par le haut
des solutions politiques
donc je pense que effectivement et la
croyais plus de monde dans la situation
actuelle sans tautou les deux
disqualifie ils n'ont plus la stature
ils doivent doivent faire un pas en
arrière et le sait effectivement les
vrais démocrates ceux qui ont vraiment
envie de trouver une solution apaisée de
trouver la solution et proposer une
solution espagnol qui n'attendent que ça
gérard deprez est ce que push damon et
mariano rajoy doivent quitter leur poste
je pense qu'ils viennent de démontrer de
l'un et de l'autre
en plus des manques par son exaltation
il faut dire que son exaltation à
quelque chose de dangereux et racole
parce qu'il a fait preuve d'une raideur
qui est incompréhensible de la part d'un
chef de gouvernement et ce qui vient de
se passer maintenant est d'ailleurs la
conséquence d'une raideur du parti
populaire qui a pu ré depuis des années
au puley requis en 2010 déjà en fait
avait attaqué le statut d'autonomie de
la catalogne et qu'elle avait obtenu en
2006 2006 et qui la fait qu'il a fait
casser par la justice mais je suis je
suis de l'avis de mon collègue français
gens crient pas certain que la médiation
européenne soit quelque chose
d'important
du point de vue des nationalistes
catalans une médiation européenne
c'est pour les aider à obtenir
l'indépendance à trouver les moyens de
leur permettre de sortir du cadre
espagnol tout en restant dans le cadre
européen
et ça je me refuse l'europe est
construite
pour dépasser le nationalisme pas pour
encourager le nationaliste et donc je
n'imagine pas que l'on puisse maintenant
comme le veulent les nationalistes
catalans faire appel à nu l'union
européenne pour aider au bon
aboutissement de leurs revendications
mais là l'idée les tongiens aussi
d'aller de permettre d'éviter de relance
d'accord avec l'idée que la
responsabilité principale ici un
concerne et les catalans et les
espagnols et le reste de l'espagne c'est
eux qui doivent trouver la
responsabilité collective qui vive mais
qui leur permet de sortir de la crise
mais je pense personnellement que les
deux dirigeants
objectivement son disque a senti qu'il
fallait que d'autres personnes puissent
prendre le relais dans une politique de
dialogue mais qui fleure match
évidemment c'est une question est ce que
en vous entendant moi je suis je suis
bien d'accord qui sont disqualifiés je
suis bien d'accord aussi qu'il faudrait
que d'autres prennent le relais nous
revient le là on en arrivait en
actuellement en espagne en catalogne sur
une telle radicalisation position c'est
qu'on ne trouve pas ces personnes
justement pour fredonner faire ce pas en
avant donc on sait pas ça pour soi quand
on a besoin en fait de tierces personnes
qui viennent et qui permet d'avoir ce
dialogue et qui s'est pas la commission
européenne
par exemple on sait d'autre ambition
devenir tout ce qu'on demande
on peut effectivement discuté parce que
quelqu'un qui permettent ce dialogue
parce qu'on a une telle radicalisation
une telle intel l'écart entre les
différentes positions on a besoin
effectivement de ses deux soeurs ça peut
être effectivement la commission de
venise du conseil de l'europe s'est fait
ça pourrait permettre effectivement
c'est un je suis d'accord alors on sent
quand même un embarras un haut niveau
des institutions européennes comme des
voisins en fête de madrid
il ya eu hier
un débat donc qui est prévue mercredi
après-midi au parlement européen sur
cette question il a fallu se bagarrer
déjà pour le mettre à l'agenda
comment se fait-il aujourd'hui que y ait
autant d'atermoiements sur cette
question gérard deprez peut-être mais je
ne sais pas ce que vous appelez les
atermoiements dans ce qui s'est passé
c'est en espagne à une situation de
blocage qui vient de se débloquer d'une
manière un peu dramatique
je tiens quand même à dire que dans tout
ce qui s'est passé du côté de la
catalogne
il y a un je m'excuse du mot il y à une
imposture de la part des dirigeants
nationalistes pourquoi il laisse croire
que l'indépendance de la catalogne
aurait pour conséquence que la catalogne
va faire partie immédiatement si elle
est indépendante de l'union européenne
c'était faux skf c'est faux et juncker
l'a rappelé en disant qu'il publierait
pas les salaires et d'autres d'un pays
car là bas on se comporte comme si
véritablement demain l'indépendance
avait entraîné de plain-pied l'adhésion
à l'union européenne
c'est faux parce qu'il faudra que la
catalogne sorte de l'union européenne
tiers devient indépendante et pour
rentrer dans l'union européenne il
faudrait l'accord unanime de tous les
états membres y compris de l'état
espagnol
donc c'est comme dans le break 6 il ya
une partie de la campagne menée par les
nationalistes qui est basé sur de
fausses informations
je dirais même sur des mensonges de
fleurs marché des mensonges de la part
du camp catalan non tout ce qui montre
qu'on a besoin d'avoir un dialogue et de
se mettra d'accord en fait entre lui
avant catalan comme l'espagne n'y a pas
d'autres sorties possibles c'est-à-dire
pour respecter à la fois à l'état de
droit et en plus répondre à un problème
politique
le seul moyen c'est d'en parler et de
trouver une solution qui soit accordé
leur nous par exemple on a proposé
depuis très longtemps un référendum qui
soit toutes les garanties qu'ils soient
accordés et pourquoi pas avant une
réforme constitutionnelle qui permettent
d'ouvrir justement là cette réforme qui
permettrait d'avoir une véritable état
fédéral et à la fin juin vote dans
l'indifférence domi et en catalogne qui
permet justement une solution dialoguer
négocier et dans martin tu ne me sur
l'idée du référendum je suis prêt à
partager mais référendum on vers quelle
population uniquement les catalans je
pense que la carte la catalogne
aujourd'hui quoique l'on dise elle fait
partie intégrante de l'espagne je pense
que le reste de l'espagne a son mot à
dire même si majorité d'espagnols
effectivement condamne la violence
utilisée par la rouille et
sont aussi peiné de voir la situation
catalan
donc voyez c'est pas simple est-ce qu'on
est ce que en tire demande l'avis
uniquement aux seuls catalans ont dix
ans au reste de l'espagne ça ne vous
regarde pas ça va aussi créer d'autres
problèmes mais je trouve quand même pour
revenir à au débat initial je pense
qu'en espagne il ya suffisamment de sage
entre guillemets pour se mettre autour
d'une table et réfléchir paisiblement à
quelle est la situation
regardez la situation basque le taa
déposer les armes depuis longtemps je je
je je connais pas trop bien mais je
pense que la situation au pays basque
est plutôt en tout cas l m'a l'air
plutôt apaisé on a réussi à trouver une
solution je pense que l'autonomie en
temps quand même de violence et pas
cinquante mille morts donc je pense que
l'assuré videmment mais villa mais
l'exemple parce que soit le celui à
suivre pour la catalogne mais comme ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que après
la violence il ya quand même eu des gens
des personnes sensées sensibles qui ont
dit ça ne peut plus durer 9 contre une
solution politique
alors je ne sais pas si elle convient
totalement aux basques mais ça m'a l'air
d'être plutôt le cas pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas trouver la même solution
je pense que le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'on a passé plus de trente ans de deux
coups de pistolet dans la nuque au pays
basque pour arriver à voir des gens
sensés donc j'espère quand même qu'en
catalogne on va arriver c'est la ville
beaucoup plus rapidement bon alors le
russe ne s'est pas vraiment le ja ja
riise de polarisation de radicalisation
et déjà l'association est déjà dans
l'arrivée en fait un exemple basque avec
eta
y'aura pas l'exemple bassin telle quelle
que soit l'histoire va pas se reproduire
tel quel
non mais ce qu'il ya un risque de
violence oui bien sûr parce qu'on prend
plus l'histoire quand même assez récente
en espagne quand même pas une histoire
magnifiquement démocratique on a une
guerre civile en 36 ans a eu le
franquisme après donc a quand même
beaucoup d'émotion qui sont dues à sa
version c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de
faire tout ce je pense un appel à la non
escalade actuelle
la dne scala et aux dialogues
effectivement donc moi j'espère déjà
j'étais assez des super fière par le
discours du roi parce que je pense qu'il
a manqué une belle occasion justement
pour s'ouvrir en tant que chef d'état
sur le dialogue mais j'espère aussi le
merlon catalans ne va pas déclarer
unilatéralement indépendant ce qui
serait une erreur historique
je ne veux pas défendre le roi parce que
j'étais surpris aussi par le ton de son
intervention
mais peut-être que c'est en espagne
comme c'est le cas en belgique
c'est à dire le roi ne peut dire que les
choses que le premier ministre accepte
qu'ils disent je ne sais pas si c'est la
situation constitutionnelle en espagne
est en tout cas un belgique le roi ne
peut pas faire autre chose qu'un
discours qui est approuvée par le
gouvernement qui est en place à ce
moment là bon peut-être que c'était des
mandats jouer malheureusement mais là je
suis je rejoins kennedy
il aurait pu se mettre au dessus de la
mêlée et personnes justement que ça je
suis là mais qui permettrait sûrement la
prostitution
de toute façon on suivra ce dossier
merci en tout cas on continue nous
sommes donc ici je le rappelle sur la
place de la cathédrale à la place du
château à strasbourg et strasbourg c'est
donc la capitale du siège du parlement
européen s'est inscrit dans les traités
et c'est un des serpents de mer dont
seule l'union européenne elle secret
cela fait des années qu'on entend parler
du déménagement donc du parlement de
strasbourg
c'est du moins ce que beaucoup de
parlementaires souhaitent en en ayant un
petit peu ras-le-bol un de ces
transhumance mensuelle entre bruxelles
et strasbourg pourquoi parce que ça
coûte cher parce que ça pollue mais bien
entendu c'est hors de question pour
strasbourg et pour la france
reportage de fabien rey caire
[Musique]
à 50 ans hakim qui recoupe dirige sa
propre centrale de taxi pour ce
strasbourgeois impossible d'imaginer sa
ville sans le parlement européen la
bataille du siège
il connaît il ya 17 ans déjà quand je
suis arrivé le premier soir j'y
travaille et il y avait parlement déjà
là j'entendais des gens tendaient des
choses en disant que le parlement va
partir voilà 17 ans après le parlement
est toujours là le parlement est là
c'est vrai qu'il ya plus de monde ça
bouge plus 751 eurodéputés leurs
assistants de nombreux fonctionnaires et
interprète
en tout quelques 3000 personnes
travaillent ici quatre jours par mois
car le parlement de se réunir à
strasbourg que pour les sessions
plénières le reste du travail
parlementaire se fait à bruxelles
317 jours par an le bâtiment reste vide
coûts annuelle de la transhumance 114
millions d'euros
de quoi faire grincer des dents sur le
plan de l'efficacité financière
l'efficacité du travail ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens d'avoir un parlement
qu'à 140 km2 des autres institutions
européennes et donc il y aura intérêt à
tout centraliser à bruxelles alors bien
sûr on pourrait tout centraliser à
strasbourg mais là le coût du
déménagement serait vraiment
astronomiques et donc franchement ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas réaliste
de plus les allers retours incessants
entre strasbourg et bruxelles
roger très près de 19 mille tonnes de
co2 dans l'atmosphère pour bart staes du
parti vert européen
cet éparpillement géographique n'est
plus tenable ça coûte énormément
d'argent
c'est une perte de temps il faut voyager
et c'est pas bien pour pour
l'environnement si on veut faire quelque
chose en faveur du climat
peut-être qu'on pourrait essayer de
trouver un arrangement
un arrangement tout pourrait faciliter
le break site en avril dernier bart
staes fait une proposition rapatriés de
londres à strasbourg l'agencé européenne
du médicament et ses 8000 agents en
échange le parlement irait à bruxelles
pour les français c'est hors de question
en aucun cas on peut imaginer un troc
d'âge ans contre le parlement européen
s'est pas envisageable le parlement à
strasbourg
là ça correspond à une certaine idée de
l'union européenne
c'est l'europe des citoyens ceux qui
sont opposés à ce parlement à strasbourg
ont très souvent une autre vision
l'idée d'une europe qui se concentre
uniquement sur le marché commun l'europe
économique ou financière pour jouer la
proximité
le parlement vient d'inaugurer un nouvel
espace à disposition des visiteurs
je clique sur ain sont des jets son
activité parlementaire
j'ai les infos des tweets etc
et puis surtout j'ai la possibilité
d'envoyer un message directement aux
parlementaires strasbourg où l'europe
des citoyens contre l'europe du marché
l'argumentaire est bien rodé
catherine trautmann a été maire de la
ville et députée européenne entouré
d'élus locaux
elle organise la riposte contre les anti
strasbourg et trois capitales
européennes à savoir bruxelles capitale
exécutive luxembourg capital juridique
strasbourg capitale parlementaire si le
triangle institutionnel qui permet l
équilibre des pouvoirs un triangle
institutionnel qui a ses limites car
contrairement à bruxelles la capitale
alsacienne n'a pas d'aéroport
international qui il n'est pas facile de
venir de bucarest à strasbourg j'ai des
responsabilités politiques dans mon pays
et ça m'empêche de prendre le seul vol
direct qui par le lundi matin et rentrer
le jeudi soir autre point noir le
logement pendant les semaines de session
c'est la flambée des prix les hôtels
multiplient leurs tarifs par quatre
nos problèmes c'est quoi c'est
l'accessibilité ça engage la
responsabilité d'état à nos côtés et
c'est aussi je dois le dire parfois les
députés rouspète et je les comprends
c'est le prix des hôtels pour lesquelles
j'ai toujours voulu que nous puissions
avoir un tarif de cession beaucoup plus
abordable pour les assistants et pour
nenê 6 jeudi après midi
fin de la parenthèse strasbourgeoise
valentina assistante parlementaire
travaille pour une députée suédoise
elle vit à bruxelles et ça fait quinze
ans qu'elle fait la navette
moi j'ai trois enfants et c'est toujours
mon mari aussi il va voyager pour le
travail donc on doit toujours bien
s'organiser quand il ya la session on ne
peut pas voyager c'est ça rendre
vraiment le travail peu moins efficace
depuis difficile pour les parlementaires
comme tous les mois un thalys
spécialement affrétés par le parlement
européen ramène les députés chez eux à
bruxelles
[Musique]
pour chaque personne qui se
la caravane parlementaires se remet en
route les députés reviendront dans un
mois un parlement deux sièges tant que
c'est à strasbourg que ce vote les lois
de l'europe
ce va-et-vient n'est pas près de
s'arrêter
[Musique]
alors en plateau le débat a déjà démarré
un sentait que la situation était
effectivement critique entre ceux qui
disent c'est du racket s'est organisée
on n'en peut plus moi mon vol depuis
madrid et nous coûte 1000 euros edouard
martin ce qui n'est pas temps de régler
enfin cette situation on peut la régler
de manière très simple tout centraliser
à strasbourg où il faut arrêter dans
opel la commission il faut arrêter mais
fait de strass européenne attendait si
le premier à tous ceux qui sont
soudainement soucieux de l'utilisation
du denier public et ils ont raison tous
ceux qui sont soucieux des émissions de
co2 par cette transhumance une fois par
par mois et je veux simplement souligné
que ce sont les mêmes
nous avons eu la réforme ets les
émissions de co2 ce sont les mêmes côté
très très très très généreux avec tous
les pollueurs de la terre ils ont donné
des millions des millions de tonnes de
droits à polluer gratuitement et là on
parle pas du coût mais si on veut parler
si on veut parler simplement de coûts
regardons exactement quel est le coût
aussi de tous ceux qui sont à luxembourg
par exemple et qui se déplacent de
manière régulière il ya aussi une partie
de la commission luxembourg qui se
déplacent peut-être même plus que nous
et bizarrement bizarrement en eau
stigmatise jamais la place du luxembourg
il faut là aussi problème selon vous
problème de mon point de vue c'est un
coup d'hypocrisie leader on l'a un peu
dit une dame je peux comprendre qu'il
dit mme vous comprenez moi mon mari
travaille moi aussi je travaille
n'attendez mais quand on est candidat à
une élection comme celle là elle est
assistante un non mais oui mais oui mais
lorsqu'on postule à ce bonhomme de
travail vous connaissez les contraintes
c'est moi aussi toute la semaine je
laisse mon épouse et mes enfants
seul toute la semaine donc si c'est un
problème insurmontable de manière
personnelle je viends ne se présente pas
gérard deprez
moi je fais pas la guerre à strasbourg
j'aime bien ce sera sans merci qui
rassure des faluns la question des pana
je suis pour un siège unique et ça ne
concerne pas uniquement strasbourg tu
viens d'en dire un mot
ça concerne aussi luxembourg savez vous
que pour l'instant des services du
parlement européen sont localisés à
luxembourg quand vous réservez une
simple dans le parlement de bruxelles
l'administration se trouve à strasbourg
dans mon nez dans une incohérence
absolument totale et donc je pense que
ça serait beaucoup plus rationnel dans
la voir sur le plan de la gestion des
finances publiques
parce que le côté quand même appréciable
vous savez l'écoutent les plus objectifs
valent des millions d'euros pour un coût
de plus de la cour des comptes d'un
couteau qui est supérieur à 100 millions
d'euros par an alors il ya un autre
chiffre que je veux citer le parlement
de strasbourg n'est occupé que pendant
qu'elle génère moi oui 317 jours par an
il est vigilante avait alors dû 3,15 et
attendez je termine je sais qu'ils ont
pris 3 ce qui veut dire que chaque
semaine parce qu'il faut l'entretenir
pour le chauffer folle éclairé pour le
garder sa coupe
trois cent cinquante six mille euros par
semaine et donc selon moi la meilleure
des solutions est de localiser toutes
les institutions parlementaires
commission et conseil russe et que
strasbourg et des compensations qui soit
significative
le désir était là alors c'est clair que
si on regarde ça d'un point de vue
d'efficacité économique l'efficacité
énergétique et l'efficacité politique il
faudrait avoir un siège unique
après il faut savoir exactement qu'est
ce qu'on propose effectivement pour
pouvoir régler ce problème que je crois
parfaitement
est ce que tu as pu dire avant est ce
que ressentent les gens à strasbourg
c'est tout à fait logique donc je pense
qu'on peut faire plusieurs propositions
déjà d'un point de vue politique parce
que je pense qu'il faut pas perdre cette
attache à strasbourg devant une
politique on pourrait même imaginer par
exemple que le débat de l'union chaque
année une fois par an se fasse à
strasbourg pour ne pas perdre ce point
la tâche entre la france et l'allemagne
a prévu historique on pourrait imaginer
aussi par exemple que tout l'argent
qu'on économise avec cette transhumance
qu'on fait eh ben on l'investît à
strasbourg justement pour cette
transition et on pourrait imaginer par
exemple aussi que l' agence du
médicament au notre agence soit
installée à strasbourg c'est à dire que
on répond absolument à toutes les
questions qu'elle était quand même on
peut avoir un siège unique
oui mais si on l'a déjà fait en bavent
un siège unique on peut avoir une
compensation économique et compensations
politiques émotionnelles qui est très
important pour strasbourg
et là on peut régler de cette façon tous
les problèmes est beaucoup plus efficace
et aussi avoir une vision pour
strasbourg très clair et politique
edouard martin est ce que ce serait pas
pérenne que d'avoir le parlement quatre
jours par allons évidemment
lorsqu'en balance des chiffres de sa
personne c'est des sommes astronomiques
puis 200 millions d'euros d'ailleurs les
chiffres sont contestés de part et
d'autre
mais si on reprend ça uniquement le coût
de la démocratie par citoyens européens
ces dix centimes c'est 10 centimes le
coût de la démocratie elle et moi je ne
suis pas sûre et la démocratie ne soit
pas plus faible si le parlement est à
bruxelles excusez nous mais faible si le
siège unique et à strasbourg n'ont pu
pourquoi pourquoi bruxelles donc si on
en plus il ya des travaux
potentiellement dans l'hémicycle de
bruxelles qui est en train de
s'effondrer qui sont quand même estimé à
un demi milliard dont vous savez moi ce
que je veux dénoncer ici parler ce sont
à chaque fois les mêmes qui montent au
créneau contre strasbourg etc et et je
commence à être fatigué de cela parce
que ce sont des arguments fallacieux
parfois ce sont des arguments fallacieux
de temps je peux vous dire qu'une bonne
partie des députés européens une bonne
partie des députés européens sont aussi
propriétaires de leur logement à
bruxelles et ça les embête une semaine
par mois d'être obligés de quitter leur
appartement leur famille leur confort
pour venir à strasbourg et en plus c'est
nativement ça leur coûte un peu de
hauteur dans tout ça c'est sentir un peu
du des cas personnels tout ça est arrêté
mais ça que c'est vraiment juste droite
et gauche passait sur nous les verts a
toujours défendu cette position
on a voté contre la réforme de l'été est
par exemple donc là je pense qu'il faut
pas il faut éviter c'est de cesser trucs
et prendre un peu d'hôtes à dire voilà
d'un point de vue politique
d'un point de vue économique un point de
vue émotionnel comment on fait pour
solutionner ce problème
au delà des cas personnels des
eurodéputés et des fonctionnaires oui et
moi j'ai fait des propositions qui sont
très concrets du helmand sur la
compensation économique sur la
compresseur surpris et sur la convention
nationale et je pense que c'est par là
avec 1,7 ya deux choses la première je
pense qu'il ya une majorité qui devient
de plus en plus écrasante au parlement
européen pour souhaiter un siège unique
à bruxelles pour autant que les vols
successifs
je reconnais qu'on peut se faire que
s'il ya unanimité
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
français de marquer son accord donc il
faudra convaincre l'opinion publique et
le gouvernement français et ça ne pourra
se faire que si on propose à la france
et en l'occurrence à strasbourg un deal
honorable je prends quelques exemples si
demain par exemple on fait un progrès
spectaculaire dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et qu'on crée un billet
européen
on peut localiser à strasbourg si demain
on a besoin d'un quartier général parce
qu'on va faire on va avancer dans le
domaine de la défense comme il au niveau
européen que l'état major général des
armées européennes sont localisés en
flammes ou que vous ayez encore d'autres
solutions de cet ordre là je ne vois pas
ce que strasbourg y perdrait je vois ce
qu'on gagnerait sur le plan économique
et je vois ce que ça signifierait sur le
plan politique et d'un martin c'est
quand même extraordinaire
vous savez comme vous l'avait dit en
début de reportage s'est inscrit dans
les traités le siège du parlement et il
était à strasbourg
lorsque y compris avec beaucoup d'autres
groupes politiques nous parlons des
choses beaucoup plus politique qui
affecte la vie des citoyens
par exemple le fait qu'il ferait
peut-être sortir se rendant sur certains
domaines de le vote unanime il fera
peut-être la majorité qualifiée on nous
répond non mais les traités nous
l'interdisent parce que c'est très
confortable politiquement de dire çà et
là tout d'un coup ça ne pose aucun
problème à personne de changer les
traités uniquement pour déménager le
siège
alors ok dans le siège unique mais le
siège unique peut se faire à strasbourg
strasbourg c'est comme une ville qui a
réussi à concilier les bureaux
institutionnelle et la vie aussi de la
ville alors que les quartiers
institutionnel de bruxelles c'est
uniquement des bureaux des bureaux et
des bureaux vous allez à poster lorsque
vous allez à bruxelles en dehors des
sessions c'est un quartier qui est mort
il n'y a pas de vie ça c'est là
l'équilibré des où vous lisez bien si la
france obtient en fait une compensation
ne trompa fin et avec le break s'est
enfin gardé agence est ce que ce serait
une possible est temps de nous parler de
troc
on parle souvent de la catalogne au
crédit est longue et il fallait être des
solutions tout ça mais c'était la même
chose on va dialoguer on va s'asseoir on
va voir les différents problèmes qu'on a
on peut pas non plus rayés de la carte
est un problème écologique dans cette
transhumance parler de la carte qui
un problème effectivement pour les
fonctionnaires et pour un député peut
pas régler un problème qu'il ya des abus
aussi aider comme hidayat va pas régler
aussi rien d'un coup de crayon aussi que
des solutions ont été proposées qui
s'entraînent une fade et je repose la
question et que j'ai posée j'ai fait
trois propositions concrètes et j'aurais
mieux à savoir si c'est qu'on veut si on
peut en discuter ou pas par exemple
elles sont très concrètes elles ne
viennent pas des news du néo libéralisme
le plus effréné reviennent de ces écolos
qui pensent justement avant tout aux
personnes aux citoyens au sein de
l'union européenne donc je pense quand
même qui a déjà que l'on me sentirai
conservateurs dont quand même une qu'une
certaine marge pour pouvoir débattre de
ça et se dire voilà à swing mais la
question du ciel le problème smash ap
qu'il est je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord pour dialoguer mais vous voyez
le le dis que tu nous propose c'est de
dire un dialogue sur la base de tout
mettre à bruxelles il est où élie houle
espace de dialogue et les négociations
mais moi je suis d'accord pour dire
effectivement dialoguons sur faut-il ou
pas un siège unique ça je suis d'accord
je suis ouvert la discussion mais vous
mettez dans d'emblée lalalalala
prérogatives que le siège unique doit
être forcément à bruxelles non ça vous
n'avez pas de dialogue possible mais à
toutes les démocraties et nous sommes
tous des démocrates
la conviction démocratique est aussi
temps que j'ai vous que chez le curé lui
que chez moi car cela on a toutes les
sociétés démocratiques le parlement et
prendre exécutif pour le compte c'est
une réalité c'est une réalité mais je
vois aussi messieurs
alors je vois bien que de toute façon va
pas réussir à vous mettre d'accord cette
fois là une fois de plus on suivra ce
dossier merci à vous
c'est la fin de cette émission
malheureuse on merci à vous de nous
avoir accompagnés par ce temps un petit
peu frisquet sur le parvis de la
cathédrale c'est la fin de cette
émission mais pas de panique on se
retrouve à bruxelles la semaine
prochaine au plus tôt vous retrouverez
ahmed tazir mon compère de fibres
bruxelles donc depuis le parlement
européen à bruxelles
merci à vous et très bonne sur des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]